3D printing is so cool.
As the technology gets cheaper and better,
it won’t cost an arm and leg, but it certainly
could make one!
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
3D printing technology is getting crazier
by the day, from ballgowns, to bicycles, to
instruments, seems like anything can be printed
out of plastic.
One of the best things to come from this technology
is it’s ability to improve the design of
artificial limbs.
We’ve talked before on DNews about how 3D
printed limbs could help people.
But what about animals?
Oh yes here’s some adorable ways 3D printing
has saved animals.
Derby the dog can play fetch with his best
friends thanks to 3D printed legs.
You see this particular pooch was born with
deformed front legs.
His foster mom rescued him from a shelter
and refused to let his disability define him.
He first got fitted with a cute little cart
which supported his upper body, but unfortunately
limited his movement, he had to stick to sidewalks
and he couldn’t use stairs.
3D Systems, a company based out of South Carolina
designed artificial legs for Derby.
But unlike a cart system, these prosthetics
are designed for running!
They look like the blades paralympic athletes
might wear.
Now this lucky dog can frolic through the
grass with the best of them.
And 3D printing is for the birds too!
Tieta, a female tucan lost a huge chunk of
her beak while being trafficked in Rio de
Janeiro.
Leaving her unable to eat properly or fend
for herself, she could only eat by throwing
food into the air trying to catch it.
Which didn’t work so well.
Only about a third of the time.
Thankfully she was rescued.
In a team effort between a wildlife management
group Instituto Vida Livre and three Brazilian
universities, Tieta got a new lease on life.
The team used a deceased bird’s beak as
a model to design a new one for Tieta.
In just two hours of printing and 40 minutes
of surgery she was almost as good as new.
It’s a light beak, weighing only 4g.
It’s basically a small 3D printed plastic
piece that’s then, covered with nail polish
and sealed with a special polymer made from
the castor oil plant.
She’s still unfortunately not fit enough
to survive in the wild, but she’s a lot
better than she was!
Now she can eat normally and even use her
beak to clean herself.
Beauty the Bald Eagle lost the top of her
beak thanks to a shot from a poacher.
Left to die in Alaska, she was rescued by
raptor biologist Janie (Fink) Veltkamp.
While some birds can regrow their beaks, experts
didn’t think hers would, and many recommended
the bird be euthanized.
But Veltkamp wasn’t ready to give up hope
yet.
In a fateful meeting with engineer Nate Calvin,
the two hatched a plan to help get Beauty
a new beak.
Thanks to a volunteer team of specialists,
Beauty was fitted with a 3D printed upper
beak in 2008.
She could feed herself and preen and just
be a big happy bird.
But in the past 7 years, her natural beak
has partially regrown!
While it’s still not at it’s original
shape and size, she can now eat salmon all
by herself without the prosthetic.
Probably my favorite though is the story of
Winter.
Nearly ten years ago a young dolphin was found
caught up in a crab fishing net.
Suffering extensive damage to her tail, it
had to be amputated.
For two years she depended on her human caretakers
for nearly everything.
But a great team of handlers and scientists
came together design her a new tail in 2007.
Since then a movie WITH MORGAN FREEMAN was
made about her story.
She lives at the Clearwater Marine Aquarium
in Clearwater, Fla. where she continues to
inspire millions today.
It doesn’t take an expert to help an animal
in need.
Stumpy the turtle lost her leg due to infection.
But rather than let her spend her remaining
years hobbling around, a group of six elementary
students in Savannah Georgia had a better
idea.
After being inspired by another lucky turtle
with a lego prosthetic, the students designed
a ball caster like leg that attaches to her
shell.
A design which can help her easily move in
any direction.
Using their school’s 3D printer, and a little
help from their teacher, they helped Stumpy
be not so stumpy anymore, maybe she should
be called Rolly.
While most of these are heart warming stories,
3D printing is insanely awesome.
Not only does the technology enable a faster,
cheaper, and easier way to make things, it
allows for custom designs.
A game changer for prosthetics.
It can be super expensive if prosthetics wear
out and break and need a replacement part.
Now a new part can be printed in a number
of hours!
And as the technology gets easier and more
affordable, now almost anyone can help an
animal in need.
You know what else makes us feel all warm
and fuzzy about the future?
Intel creates the breakthrough technologies
that make amazing experiences possible.
Having Intel inside makes for better experiences
outside.
Intel drives innovation with products like
processors, wearables and IOT devices, and
within data centers.
In the PC and beyond.
So what do you think the coolest thing ever
printed was? have you ever used one?
tell us about it in the comments below